NARRATOR: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So in
terms of what we're
going to be
discussing today, it's
various aspects of
feed-forward loops.
So first of all, we will go
over this idea of a network
motif in more detail.
We talked it about a
little bit in the context
of auto regulation.
There is a simple argument
there that auto regulation
is a network motif.
And in order to understand
how to detect network motifs,
in general we have to look
at a little more detail
at these subgraphs and the
frequency that they'll appear
and so forth.
And then after seeing that the
feed-forward loop is a network
motif, then there's
this question-- oh, well
what might be the
functional significance?
And in the chapter
that you just read,
you found this so-called
coherent type one
feed-forward loop has a
nice attribute-- that it's
sign sensitive delay element.
The incoherent type
one has the feature
that it's a pulse generator,
and kind of related to that,
it can also speed up
the response time.
So it can make the response
time for turning on shorter.
So speed up response
rate if you'd like.
We'll also maybe
say a little bit
that there's been later
work demonstrating
that the incoherent type one
can also access a fold detector.
So it can sense changes
in the fold change
of concentrations of proteins.
And then finally,
we'll say something
about how you can extend
these ideas of a network motif
to larger structures.
In particular, how you get
useful temporal programs.
So we start out
with this network
that is kind of--
our base network
is this transcription network
characterized in E. coli.
And we've already
talked about it some.
So there's going to be some
measure the number of nodes
and the number of edges.
So we have N nodes,
and we have E edges.
This is from experimental
measurements of-- what
is it that regulates what?
Now from this, we'll have
some set of directed edges,
because indeed, we
know that there's
going to be some transcription
factor that will regulates
some other protein.
And what we want to
know is are there
patterns that occur
more regularly than what
you'd expect based on chance.
Now auto regulation
we found indeed
appeared more regularly,
or more frequently than you
would expect by chance.
And there are a limited
number of other network motifs
that have that property.
And in particular, we'll
kind of analyze this idea
of the feed-forward loop.
Now in the network that we
kind of talked about a lot,
there were around 400 genes or
proteins, and then around 500
observed edges.
And this would be
interactions or regulation.
Now there's this
idea of sparseness.
Can somebody remind
us maybe what this
is supposed to tell us about?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: There
should be roughly N
squared in total edges.
PROFESSOR: So there's N
squared possible edges.
AUDIENCE: If you just connected
everything that you connected,
and so N is about the order of
E. So roughly, there's only 1
out of 500--
PROFESSOR: And we
should be clear,
this N squared possible-- we
might even want to add directed
edges since we're-- and what we
see is that the actual number
of edges that we observe in this
real network is actually around
order N. So this sparseness,
which is also this probability
P-- if we're going to make a
network somehow that has some
similar property to
the observed network,
there's some probably P that
an actual edge will appear.
And this is given by
the observed number
of edges divided by the total
possible number of edges,
which is indeed N squared.
And what you see is that,
at least in this network,
this P is much less than one.
So this is what
we mean by sparse.
Now you can also think
about the question
of how many edges does a typical
gene have emanating from it?
Well, you can see
that it's around one.
Of course, each edge
connects two things,
so if you were to
say on average,
each gene has of one edge going
out, and one edge going in.
Of course, there
might be a reason
to believe that these
averages are not as--
well they can be misleading.
And why might the
average be misleading?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: The distribution
for heavy tails.
PROFESSOR: Right,
it's going to be
a distribution with heavy tails,
in particular on which side?
So the average is
always the average,
but I guess the
question is there
are going to be some proteins,
or some genes with many
of these outgoing edges.
And more generally,
do you expect
that-- there's a natural
limitation in all this.
Part of the value
of this approach
is that we're abstracting away
from a lot of the microscopic
or the biological details.
But every now and then it's
good to go in and think about it
a little bit.
So there's a good reason you'd
expect many proteins to not
have any outgoing edges,
and why would that be?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: For example,
a detector protein,
that only evolved one
specific function or another.
PROFESSOR: So there
are some proteins
that have rather specific
functions, you might say.
And I think that's true.
I think that's part of it.
But there's maybe
something that's
maybe even a little
bit more general that's
worth pointing out here.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Anything that's
not a transcription factor.
PROFESSOR: Anything that's not
a transcription factor, right.
We say transcription factor,
we don't ever really quite
specify.
But what it means is
that it's something
that can affect the
transcription of other things.
So we're talking about
the function of it
when we say
transcription factor.
And a majority of the
proteins in any genome
are not transcription factors.
What that means is that
they, to first order, cannot,
at least directly influence the
transcription of other genes.
So this is a reflection of
this power law distribution
that we observe.
And so you could argue
well maybe not a surprise
that this outgoing edge
distribution is power law,
because we know that there are
some transcription factors that
control many things, and
there are many proteins
they don't control
the transcription
of any other proteins directly.
But at least it's
just useful to know
what the properties of
this thing are on average
even though, for
the outgoing edges,
the average is a
little bit dangerous.
Because it's really
that most proteins don't
have any outgoing edges,
and then some have many.
All right so this is
this probability P.
And this is going to be
useful, because this P will
appear when we're
trying to construct
these random networks.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to ask how frequently or
how many of a given subgraph
you expect to appear
in this larger network
that we have here?
And we're going to characterize
each of these subgraphs
by two properties.
And in particular, if we're
going to analyze some smaller
graph, we just
have to keep track
of how many nodes
are in the subgraph,
and how many edges
are in the subgraph.
So for example, if we
have auto regulation,
then we're just talking
about little n equal to one,
little g equal to one.
Whereas in the case of
this feed-forward loop,
what is little n
and what's little g?
Well we can count now.
Here n is equal to three,
one, two, three, and g
is also equal to three.
And we're going to
find that actually
the fact that these
two numbers are equal
is somehow very
relevant in thinking
about the dynamics of
these networks later.
In this framework, when
I just draw an arrow
in the context of
a generic subgraph,
am I necessarily trying to
say that this is up regulation
of x up regulating y?
No.
So this is a bit confusing
because depending
on the context, sometimes
the arrows actually
do mean up regulation, sometimes
they just mean regulate.
And in this case, where we're
talking about subgraphs,
we're just saying
that x regulates y
in one way or another.
This is also how
we're going to write
the so-called coherent
type one feed-forward loop,
but for right now this is just
a generic feed-forward loop.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Regulate means
positive regulation?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
We say activate.
So the way that we
think about is we ask,
what's the expected
number of some subgraph G?
And indeed what we're going
to be doing for right now
is assuming this
Erdos-Renyi random network.
Now what we're told is that
this is going to look something
like the following.
could somebody explain
one of these three terms?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Well you
have to select edges,
and you have choose
them correctly.
So for each one, there's
a chance that [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So for here
what we're going to do
is, for example in this
context, we'll say,
we're going to
choose these three.
And now the question is, we
have to put in three edges
as well to connect those
nodes, and each one of them
has some probability P of
actually somehow appearing.
Because this is
what we're keeping
constant from the
original network.
So we're assuming that we
have this Erdos-Renyi network
with the same number,
say roughly 400 nodes,
and then what we're going to
do is grab maybe three of them
and ask, all right, what's
the probability that we
get these three actual edges?
So you get P to the g.
Now where does this
term come from?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Selecting a node.
PROFESSOR: So we're going
to be selecting N nodes.
We're assuming that
this N is much larger.
we have a big network,
so it's much larger than
the size of the subgraph
we're looking at,
so we don't have
to think about n times n minus
one, n minus two, and so forth.
And then there's this
factor a here as well,
which, depending on how
you do your counting--
this is a little bit tricky,
but what was a again?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: It's the number of
ways to arrange the edges.
It's a symmetry factor.
PROFESSOR: Yes, it's
a symmetry factor,
it's a way of-- there are
multiple ways of looking
at this.
You could think about
it as the number
of ways of rearranging
x, y, and z
and having the same
subgraph, the exact same one.
In this case, there's
actually no way
to rearrange x, y, and
z to have the same one.
Because x occupies
a special spot,
y is indeed again a
special spot. z is special.
So there's no
permutations that you
can do to get the same thing.
Whereas if you have this
repressilator-- now here
I'm just drawing
this as an arrow,
because again
we're just thinking
about the generic
version of these things.
So it's just when we have x,
y, and z regulating each other.
In this case, you can get the
same network by rotating these
x's, y's, and z's.
So in this case, you
get a equal to three.
For pretty much
all the conclusions
we're going to talk about,
these factors of one, two, three
don't actually end
up being relevant.
But it's good to know
that they indeed exist.
So this is fine, but it's useful
to express this in another way.
In particular, we can
always define this lambda,
which is E/N, as the mean
number of incoming edges
or the mean number
of outgoing edges.
And with this, we
can express this guy
in a way that is
surprisingly informative.
Nothing happened
except that we just
plugged this thing in here.
But by doing, we
see something that's
kind of interesting, which is
that there's reason to believe
that for many of these networks,
this lambda, this mean number
of incoming edges, that
lambda will be roughly
similar-- whether you're
talking about a network that
is 500 nodes large
or 5,000 nodes large.
And indeed in this
case, it's around one.
It's just over one.
So that means that when we think
about the number of subgraphs
that will be in
this large network,
it scales with the size
of the overall network.
We had this little
n minus little g.
And in particular, in cases
when you're analyzing a subgraph
with the same number
of nodes as edges,
then you just get
n to the 0, and it
doesn't scale with a number.
So for those, and
indeed basically
for all those subgraphs where
little n is equal to little g--
then you expect of
order one of those--
if lambda is around
one, then you
expect of order one of those
to appear in the network.
And so from a very simple
standpoint, the networks,
like the feed-forward loop that
we see that is a network motif,
the expectation is that
in a random network,
you would get around
one, maybe two.
Whereas if you see many
of them, dozens, then it's
indeed a network motif.
Are there any
questions about how
that appeared in the chapter
or the argument there?
So indeed, we can
actually just then say,
for the feed-forward
loop, we can just
go ahead and ask how many
were observed in E. coli,
this network that was
actually observed?
And this was 42 I believe.
Whereas if you do this analysis
for the Erdos-Renyi network,
you get 1.7 plus or minus 1.3.
Because these things
appear randomly,
they should be
Poisson distributed.
So you expect of
order one of them
to appear in a random
network with this same kind
of sparseness, the
same number of edges.
But we actually observe
this much larger number.
So then you can
say, all right, this
is evidence for the feed-forwad
loop being a network motif.
That for some
reason, this subgraph
appears more
frequently than what
you'd expect based on genes.
Of course, we alluded to
this on the end of class
on Tuesday, that maybe this
Erdos-Renyi network is not
the proper null model or
null network to be using.
And maybe we should use one
of these degree-preserving
networks.
So maybe we should try to
preserve more the properties
of the original network.
And So can because somebody
say a little bit of what
we mean by degree-preserving?
There's an element that our null
model here already preserves
something about the degree.
It preserves the means.
So it's not just that we picked
up some random null model,
some random ER network.
So what is it that
we want to keep
track of in this
degree-preserving network?
I saw a hand over there,
but I'm not trying
to call on people randomly.
Although I'm going to
start in the second half
of the semester,
just after drop date.
[LAUGHTER]
So we're going to
preserve not only
the mean of the incoming
and outgoing edges,
but also the actual
degree distribution.
In a very concrete
way, we can actually
just say that each node
actually does maintain
the exact same number of edges.
So in particular, here
we say that all nodes
maintain their
degree distribution
or maintain number of
incoming and outgoing.
And there was a simple
algorithm for doing that.
If you recall,
what you can do is
you can just take two edges
randomly and just swap
the locations.
And you do that
many, many times,
and you end up maintaining both
the incoming and the outgoing
number of edges.
And if you do this analysis
on a degree-preserving random
network, you get a seven
plus or minus five.
So this makes a big difference.
So if, for example, the
experimentally-observed network
had one of these feed-forward
loops, then what you'd see
is that actually, comparing
to the Erdos-Renyi,
you would have said, oh well
that that's a network motif.
Whereas comparing to
this degree-preserving,
you would have said it's not.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I don't know why
I haven't asked this before,
but is it also true that this
degree-preserving thing is
roughly Poisson in
terms of-- I mean,
should we expect
deviations always?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's close.
But I think it ends
up not being quite.
But it is close.
AUDIENCE: So is the entire
transcription network
for E. coli?
PROFESSOR: So I think that
it is, certainly now--
well you'll notice that
here there are 400 genes.
How many genes does
E. coli have, anybody?
A few thousand.
So the network that we
analyzed in that original paper
was not the full transcription
network of E. coli.
AUDIENCE: How do people--
how do figure out
the whole transcription network?
It actually sounds pretty hard.
PROFESSOR: Well figuring
out and any part of it
is actually hard in some ways.
The way that they
actually annotated
this particular
network, I'm not sure.
I mean what kind
of date would you
need in order to get at this?
Does anybody have any-- I
mean, if I asked you to do this
in your lab, what would you do?
So you could actually use
a computational program
to try to actually
estimate binding affinities
of these proteins to the DNA.
And these days
actually experimentally
you can actually just measure
for the entire proteome
basically, just the affinity of
binding to different promoters.
Of course that doesn't
prove that it's
going to regulate expression,
but that at least points you
in the right direction.
Then you could
actually, if you want,
you could just
experimentally go and put
this protein on an
inducible promoter and just
see if it does
regulate expression.
At this stage, for
something like E. coli,
we have collections
of strains where
every gene has been removed.
We have collections where
every gene has been tagged.
And of course, when I say every,
this means that it was tried
to make it for every and then
of course if it's an essential
gene you can't remove it.
And
In some cases it's hard to
attack a fluorescent protein,
and so forth.
But there are
collections both E. coli
and for budding yeast
where this has been done.
Any other questions?
Can somebody say
why it might be--
is this a surprise
that this number is
larger than this number?
And in particular, would
the degree-preserving random
network have a larger
expectation for every subgraph?
No.
But in particular, for
the feed-forward loop,
can hear somebody say why
we should have expected
that the degree-preserving
would have a larger
number than the-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: All the measures
have one outgoing edge,
and so [INAUDIBLE] distribution
towards lower numbers
of outgoing edges.
And so you would expect
more from forward loops.
PROFESSOR: I think that
the explanation had
the right flavor,
but I think there
were two inversions in there
that-- like a not and a not
turned into a-- Incidentally,
this is a non-sequitur,
but this happened to me once.
The airport in San Francisco--
I was going to the airport,
I got the wrong
airline in my head.
So I thought I was
on the wrong airline,
so I went to the wrong
terminal, but then it turned out
that I also was wrong about
which airline was in which
terminal, so then I was
actually the right terminal even
though I had just
made two mistakes.
But you can't account on
this happening all the time.
But I think there were two
things that were mixed up
in that explanation.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: For a
transcription factor,
it has many outgoing--
outcoming edges.
And you just have to--
PROFESSOR: So in
the actual network,
There are some nodes
with many outgoing edges.
And then--
AUDIENCE: You just need to
have another line between.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
You somehow just have
to add one more edge.
Because x actually has
two outgoing edges.
So there's a sense of
the feed-forward loop
here-- you can think about
x being some transcription
factor.
And then what you need
is just to get-- x might
have many, many outgoing edges.
And so to get a feed-forward
loop, what you need
is you need for one
of those genes that
are targeted to just
target another one that's
in that network.
So if you have x that's
regulating one00,
then that actually that
presents many opportunities
to generate feed-forward loops.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: At the same time
z, it's just going in.
So wouldn't that
make the [INAUDIBLE]?
Is that why there's more ingoing
edges than outgoing edges?
PROFESSOR: Now this is a
problem with verbal arguments--
you can construct anything.
And indeed, I would say
that this is an example.
What we said is that the
distribution of incoming edges
is roughly kind of similar
to an ER network in the sense
that if the mean is
one, then sometimes you
get 0, sometimes
one, sometimes two.
And they're all
kind of reasonable.
So in that sense, I'd
say this z node is not
so unusual from the standpoint
of degree-preserving network.
If z had one00 incoming
edges, then it's
certainly true what
you're saying--
that the degree-preserving
would then have fewer.
All right.
So this is the basic
argument for why
you might go and look
at what the function
of the feed-forward
loop might be.
I just want to say a few things
about this original paper
that Uri published.
So it's in Science in 2002.
"Network motifs: Simple Building
Blocks of Complex Networks."
All right.
So the authors did indeed
analyze both the E.
coli and the yeast
transcription network.
But they also analyzed a
number of other networks
to look at these
networks motifs.
So they also analyzed neurons
from C. elegans, the worm,
where the connectome has been
known for several decades now.
And again, they found that
feed-forward loops appeared
more frequently than
what would be expected,
based on the known model
of degree preserving.
And that's encouraging
is that saying, oh
maybe feed-forward
loops really are somehow
preserving some--
they're performing
some useful
information-processing task.
Of course, you always have
to worry-- there's also
the spatial arrangement.
You can worry about
a lot of things.
But that's encouraging.
He also analyzed food
webs, where in that case
feed-forward loops were
not a network motif,
but other things were,
So that's interesting.
He analyzed the design
of electronic circuits,
a forward logic chip.
I don't know that is.
But then also the
worldwide web, it's
another network people
love to analyze.
And indeed, he saw
some other patterns.
And the idea is that in
each of these contexts,
the network motifs
are different,
depending upon the microscopic
structure that's leading to it,
or the function that it's maybe
evolving towards, or whatnot.
So it's a way of getting
insight into the properties
of these complex networks.
Are there any questions
about these network--
the global network
structures, before we
get into the feed-forward
loop in particular?
So first I want to
just go ahead and do
a few of our little
concept questions.
Just because you
have the cards, and I
think that the
chapter is actually
pretty nice in the
sense of you can
read it, and get a clear
sense of what's going on.
But let's start by
just considering
this feed-forward loop, which
is this coherent type 1.
So now the arrows
actually mean activating.
So we have X going to Y. Now
it's going to be going to a Z.
But we have to remember that
now that there are two inputs,
we do have to specify
how the inputs are
going to be combined.
And for now what
we'll do is we'll
assume that it's an AND gate.
And that goes to Z. As always,
we're going to have to think.
There's some signal x and
signal y that come in here.
In many, many cases, these
transcription factors
in addition to being
regulated by another,
say transcription
factor, may also
be responsive to some signal.
And there was a nice example
of this in Uri's book
which was how E. Coli
decide whether to make
the suite of proteins
that are required
to digest the carbon source
arabinose, the sugar arabinose.
But for now, let's
just think about this.
And we want to just make
sure that we remember.
And once again, it's not
that you should necessarily
memorize these things.
But after having seen the
argument once or twice,
you should be able
to reconstruct
all of these things.
So I claimed that
somewhere in here there's
a sign sensitive delay.
Now the question is, in which
direction is there a delay.
And so it's going to
be some combination
of on and off perhaps.
And check means that it's
a delay in that direction.
Well actually we should
just from nothing there--
and D is don't know.
AUDIENCE: In that
direction you mean?
PROFESSOR: That there's a--
this means that there's a sign.
That's right.
So this would be going from
off to on, so turning on.
So this is turning on, as
compared to turning off.
And we're looking
at this is delay.
We're talking about,
this is in response to Sx
changing concentration of Z.
Any questions about what
I'm referring to in this?
AUDIENCE: Is there any Sy?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Good question I like
that right Sy is present.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So this is compared to
simple regulation, or i.e.
does the concentration
of Z immediately
start to change after
this Sx changes?
It goes from either
0 to 1, or 1 to 0.
AUDIENCE: So simple
regulation in this case
would be erase that
line between X and Y?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
And make the AND gate a--
AUDIENCE: Not an AND gate?
PROFESSOR: Not an AND
gate, exactly, yeah.
We're comparing to just if X
is just directly regulating
Z. Because what we
want to know is,
I mean what might a function
of the feed-forward loop be.
So I'll give you 15 seconds
to think through this.
Once again, it's not that
you should have memorized it.
I don't want anybody
saying that they just
couldn't read my handwriting.
AUDIENCE: So this is for the
second case we're asking?
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry.
So this is-- I'm asking about
for this feed-forward loop,
the coherent type
1 with an AND gate.
And I'm comparing,
I'm asking is there
a delay in either turning
on or turning off,
as compared to the simple
regulation of X regulating Z.
And of course, this
is my [INAUDIBLE] Sx.
And we assume that X
is already present.
Do you need more time?
All right, ready?
Three, two, one.
OK.
We got a clear majority of the
group actually is saying C.
And so we can get at this
kind of visually, graphically.
I really like graphs.
I think they're much
nicer than equations.
Different people can
agree or disagree.
but that's my--
The idea is that we have Sx.
It starts out off
and say turns on.
So if we think about the X
star, X was always around.
So means that X
star immediately--
so the signal immediately
changes X into X
star, the active version.
Now Y, and this
is why we can even
say Y star, because the
signal Y is always there.
It starts our here.
It immediately gets the signal.
So it starts coming up.
But of course, this
is an AND gate.
Which means that
you need to have
both active Y and
active X in order
to start getting
expression of Z.
So we have if we
look at Z, there's
something threshold at
which is Y starts allowing
for expression of Z. So just
because we have active X,
doesn't mean that we immediately
start getting expression
of Z. We need Y as well.
So this comes up.
However, when the
signal here goes away,
X star immediately goes away.
This is the separation
of timescale idea.
This is just a binding of
a small molecule or so.
What that means is that Y star--
is there a delay on Y star?
We're going to do a verbal.
Is there a delay before Y
star just starts coming down?
So the question, it's going
to decay exponentially
once it starts going.
Does it a start
going immediately,
or is there a delay?
So the question is, is there
a delay before the exponential
fall off of Y star.
You're going to say yes or
no, ready, three, two, one.
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No delay.
Great.
And indeed over here it's
the same thing, no delay
because of the AND gate.
Expression of Z requires
both X star and Y star.
So although Y star still
there, since it's an AND gate,
Z goes down.
That means that in this case
we have a sign sensitive delay
for turning on Z, but
not for turning off Z.
And of course,
this can be useful,
depending upon the
costs and benefits
of having false positives and
false negatives in the signal.
If this AND gate were
switched to an OR gate,
how does this thing change?
I'm going to give
you 10 seconds.
All right.
So, question is, if I
convert this to an OR gate,
does it change anything or not.
Do you need more time?
Ready, three two one.
Now we got a lot of B's.
Great.
So in this case it's coherent
type 1, feed-forward loop
with an OR gate.
I'm not going to
go over the logic.
But I encourage you, if
you're confused by this,
just make sure that you can
reconstruct the argument.
From my standpoint,
these equations I mean,
it's good to do equations.
But it's more important
to be able to understand
the logic here.
Did you have a question?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
So how is it easy to
prove experimentally
what kind of gate there is?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So the idea is
that in many cases
you can put X on an
inducible promoter.
You could put Y on an
So you can-- just some
small molecule will
allow you to control these.
And then you can measure,
say fluorescence, on Z.
And that's the
most direct things.
It's experimentally
doing it yourself.
Of course, much of the data
that you see the chapter
is kind of just looking at the
fluorescent Z as a function
of the signals that you put in.
And that's certainly
an argument for it.
And then ultimately
what you'd like
is to measure things in
multiple different ways,
confirm that it's
all consistent.
Any other questions
about this idea
of sign sensitive delay element?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
So among these 42--
these that are this type,
is it possible to look
at the actual genes,
and see if that
interrelationship actually
makes sense?
PROFESSOR: That's
a good question.
So if you look at across
both E. coli and yeast, what
you see is that of the
feed-forward loops, about half
of them are coherent
type 1, which
is one of the eight possible
kinds of feed-forward loops.
And so what you're
asking is, in this case,
so let's say there are
20 coherent type 1,
how many of them,
what fraction of them
does this all makes sense?
And it's a good question.
I don't know.
I haven't looked at it.
Because it's always
dangerous, of course,
that we find one example of
the 20 where it kind of makes
sense conceptually.
And then we go and we
test it experimentally,
and see that it all works.
And then we're convinced.
But you're pointing
out that maybe we
shouldn't be convinced yet.
AUDIENCE: But I'm just curious.
If you're proposing a functional
kind of explanation, and if
know what the genes are.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
You should be able to go and see
whether it somehow make sense.
And of course makes sense is
always a slippery concept.
Because we can always--
it's not that this radically
changes the logic.
And then in any
given circumstance
you may be say, oh well.
You can kind of wave
your arms and make up
a story where it
kind of makes sense.
But then the only way to
really feel comfortable
with it or not, is for you
yourself to go on look at them,
and see how comfortable you are
with each of those arguments.
And I haven't
actually done that.
So one more question
in this regard.
All right.
So let's imagine that instead
of thinking about changes in Sx,
with Sy present,
let's now flip things.
Let's assume that Sx
is present and ask
about Sy turning on and off.
Again with the AND
gate, I want to know
in which direction
is there a delay when
turning either on or off.
Now we're talking about
with Sy turning on or off.
Does everybody
understand the question?
I'll give you 10
seconds to make sure.
Do need more time?
Let's go ahead and vote.
Ready, three, two, one.
All right.
OK, so I'd say now it's
pretty overwhelming
that the group again
agrees that now it'll be A.
So if we have Sx equal to
1, and Sy is changing, then
in this case we don't
get any of these delays.
So there's sort of immediate
changes in Z as Sy changes.
And that's because
this is an AND gate.
If X is already there that
means that we've already
satisfied this half of it.
So then we're just reduced
to simple regulation.
This is just equivalent
to Y regulating Z.
So there are no delays either
turning on or turning off.
So what you read
about from Uri's book
is what is that the
coherent type 1 is perhaps
the most common of the
feed-forward loops observed
in these transportation
networks.
The other of the
feed-forward loops
that is distinctly
overrepresented
is this incoherent type 1.
So it's very similar, with the
exception that now what we have
is X activating Y, but now Y
is going to be repressing Z.
And we have X
again activating Z.
And we're going to
use an AND gate again.
Its edge going to Z. For me, I
find it sometimes a little bit
confusing to think about a
repression and an AND gate.
So it is useful to make sure
that we kind of understand
the logic of all these things.
So if we have say
X star, Y star,
and we can just
make sure this is
absence or presence, digital
approximation of each
of these things.
And the question is, if
we have expression of Z.
Now the way to just
think about this
is that this guy is equivalent
to kind of inverting
the sign of Y star.
And then we have an AND gate.
So this is a 0,1.
That's not an AND.
Well 0 is enough to give us a 0.
So here we get activation.
Here we don't.
And so we can do a similar kind
of story of what we did here.
Except that now instead
of Y being an activator,
it's now a repressor.
And again, we're going to
think about what happens
with the signal coming in.
Is any difference
up to this point?
Let's think about it.
Everything but
this for a second.
All right.
So this is a case
where we already
have signal Y that's allowing,
say, the Y repressor to bind.
Then we make Sx appear.
I want to know
verbally, yes or no.
Do I have to draw something
new up to this point here?
Ready, so what do I want to say?
Is there a change from this
drawing up to this point?
Ready, three, two, one.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
All right.
And that's because actually Z
starts coming up at this point.
It's very, very nerve-wracking,
these quizzes, I know.
The idea is that here
Y is now a repressor.
So it's not that you need Y in
order to get expression of Z.
Is that once you
have Y star, then you
stop getting expression of Z.
So it looks like maybe I'll
make a-- so in this case
everything's the same here.
Except that in this case you
start getting Z coming up.
And then once Y gets up to
a sufficiently high level,
it starts repressing.
In that case it might
do something like this.
Now, depending upon the
strength of that repression,
this curve might look different.
Because it could come
all the way down to 0.
Depending on if it's a
very effective repressor.
And depending upon whether
it's fully repressed or only
partially repressed,
you might think about it
as either being a pulse
generator, so you get some Z,
and then it goes away.
Or you could think
about it as a way
of increasing the
rate at which you're
able to turn this gene on.
Because it's sort of like
this negative autoregulation
idea that initially you
get lots of expression.
And then later you
stop getting as much.
Of course, here you
would get an overshoot.
But maybe that's not all bad.
So in this what you might say
is this is a pulse generator.
And this here is a way
of making t on go down.
Are there any questions
about the logic
of what happens in
this incoherent type 1?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Can you
explain the t on?
PROFESSOR: Sure.
So maybe let's zoom in.
And we can look at Z. So
it kind of gets expressed.
And then it represses like this.
And then you always have to ask,
well what do you mean by t on?
And then we have is
working definition,
which is that we say t
on is defined as there's
some equilibrium concentration.
So this is Z equilibrium.
And we often define t on
as the time in which you
get half of that concentration.
So what we do is we
take half of that.
And we say, where
does this cross?
It crosses right here.
I maybe overdid my drawing.
It's too good of a--
So t on, in this case,
would be that time right there.
Now of course you
have to say, well
what should we compare that to?
And the comparison
should be the t
on that you would have had
with just simple regulation.
So that's based on
the generation time.
And you can actually see what
the generation time is here.
Because this thing in the
absence of the repression
would have done
something like that.
So this tells us that
the simple regulation
would have lead to something
that looks like this.
So you see the t on here,
this is t on simple,
is much larger than the t on
that you actually get here.
So from this
argument there are--
we can now try to recapitulate
or recall for ourselves
the various strategies for
increasing the rate of response
to signals.
So we have, we can think about,
you want to decrease t on,
and you want to decrease t off.
And we want to think about
maybe different strategies
that we've encountered
over the last few weeks.
What were some of
the strategies?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Just having
a higher degradation?
PROFESSOR: All right,
higher degradation.
Right.
So increase degradation,
well maybe I'll
just say decrease lifetime.
Well it's the same thing.
So decrease the
protein lifetime.
And what does that do for us?
Does that decrease t on,
or does it decrease t off?
Both.
All right.
So this decreases t on,
and it decreases t off.
What were some of
the other strategies?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Negative
autoregulation.
PROFESSOR: Negative
Great.
And what does that do for us?
AUDIENCE: I think it
decreases t off and on also.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So let's do a vote.
This is a good opportunity.
This is like review for
exams for you guys right now.
All right.
So negative autoregulation,
does it decrease t on,
t off, both, neither,
or something or another?
All right, eight seconds.
Ready, three, two, one.
All right.
So we got many C's, but
many other things as well.
Right.
But indeed it's only going
to decrease t on, actually.
And that's because remember,
the negative autoregulation what
it does, is initially, it
makes a lot of this protein.
And then once you hit
the repression threshold,
then it sort of
represses itself.
And so you are able to kind of
rapidly get up to that level,
and then you clamp it there.
Whereas turning off that
just means that you just
tell to stop making it.
So it's always going to
then decay at the rate that
is dictated by its
effective lifetime, which
is kind of either
from the protein
or from the actual degradation,
or from the growth of cell.
So this only decreases t on.
And then indeed, we just
learned about another one
here, which was the
incoherent, incoherent type 1
feed-forward loop, with
kind of modest amounts
of repression, incomplete
repression or so.
And what does that do here?
Did we actually even figure
out what it did here?
Oh, we maybe didn't say.
Five seconds, again over here.
What does it-- we've-- well
I told you one half of it
already.
But what about the other half?
All right.
All right, ready?
Incoherent type 1 feed-forward
loop, what does it do?
Ready, three, two, one.
OK.
We've got again, a bunch of C's.
Indeed this is--
and of course, I'm
using the same chart for
the sign sensitive delay,
and for the time to
turn on turn off.
So I hope that that
doesn't confuse you.
If it does, I'm sorry.
All right.
So this is, it decreases
t on, but not t off.
This is an AND gate.
So you need both active
X star and Y star.
So the moment that
you make Sx go away,
then it's going to
start-- oh wait.
I'm explaining a different one.
OK.
Sorry.
This is the time.
So we're at Z. But yeah, it
immediately starts going down.
But at the same normal
rate of effective lifetime.
Many more ways to make a protein
quickly, than to get rid of it
quickly.
Are there any questions
about what we've said here?
So while we're on the topic
of kind of response times
and so forth, it's
important to remember
that the characteristic
time for all these things
is kind of the generation
time, or the protein lifetime.
So these are ways of processing
information over time scales
that are kind of like
minutes, maybe even
tens of minutes, maybe hours.
So it's rather slow.
Now is that, in general.
Going to be good
enough for everything
that a cell needs to do?
No.
So it's important to highlight
that transcription is slow.
So that means that transcription
networks are going to be slow.
And that's both
because you actually
have to do transcription and
translation, and so forth.
But also you just have to change
the concentrations of proteins.
So if you need to kind of
respond to things more rapidly,
what is it then you need to do?
AUDIENCE: Phosphorylate.
PROFESSOR: Phosphorylate, yeah.
It's all about
phosphorylation, yes.
Indeed, phosphorylate-- so you
need, if you want to be fast,
you can't be changing overall
protein concentrations.
You have to change
protein state.
Right, and phosphorylation
is kind of the classic way
of doing that.
so I just want to highlight
that for speed you need just
to do kind of protein networks.
So we're not
actually going to be
reading the chapter analyzing
these map kinase cascades,
and so forth.
But if you're interested
in such things,
I very much encourage you do so.
It's also nice
chapters, maybe not
as nice as the first
four, which is part
of why we're not reading them.
But it's a very important
insight, in the sense
that we've spent a lot of time
talking about transcription
networks, just because
there's a lot of, I think,
simple, beautiful things
that you can say about them.
Whereas they are intrinsically
limited in terms of speed.
So for much of what
a cell needs to do,
it has to already have
the proteins there.
And then you can take advantage
of these rapid processes.
So we talked about
Sx rapidly binding,
changing the state of X. From
the standpoint of transcription
networks, we just draw
this as a straight line.
It's rapid.
But what that's saying
is that if you just
change states of
proteins, then you
can do a lot of information
processing rather rapidly.
And you don't have to do just
a simple thing of Sx binding
X. You can also have proteins
regulating each other,
and performing logic functions
at the protein-only level.
What I want to do for
the last 20 minutes
is say something about
temporal programs
that can be implemented with
sort of larger network motifs.
And in particular this
is material basically
from chapter five of the
book, which again we're
not to be reading.
I think it's again,
it's beautiful
but it's really simple.
So I think that in 20 minutes
we can cover it just fine.
So for many cases, for example,
in the context of metabolic
pathways, it might be the case
that you have some protein
we'll call them Z's.
So you'll have some protein
Z1 that does something.
So that catalyzes-- so we might
have some molecule one that's
converted into module
two, by Z1, converted
into molecules three by Z2.
So many metabolic pathways
have this structure
where there are a
series of enzymes
that are doing something to the
product of the previous enzyme.
Now the question is, let's say
that this is some carbon source
and we didn't before.
But now it's appeared
in our environment.
So what we would like
is we'd like to start
digesting that carbon source.
Or in the flip
side, maybe we have
to make some complex molecule
or an amino acid or so.
And so then what we're doing
is we're building something
up, coming down.
Now in either case, if before
you weren't making these Z
proteins, but now you
want them, a question is,
maybe you could just make
them all at the same time.
But maybe it would be better
to make some of them first,
and some of them later.
What do you think?
Let's say for the
sake of argument
that you would want to have
some first, and some later,
which ones would you want first?
AUDIENCE: The ones
that you use first?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, the
ones you need first.
So you'd maybe want to first
have Z1, then Z2, et cetera.
It's a trivial statement,
but you might not actually
think about it.
And the question is how
might we be able to do this.
Well there's a very simple thing
called a single input module.
The idea here is there's
some transcription factor
X, which actually does
this fabulous thing where
it creates all these guys.
Interestingly, this also often
has autoregulation in order to,
for example, stabilize
the concentration of it.
But the reason it's called
a single input module is
because the network motif is
saying not just that X makes
many Z's.
That actually you
can't actually argue
that that's a network
motif, from the standpoint
of a degree preserving network.
Because of course, this
is just saying well
some nodes activate
many other nodes.
And in a degree preserving
network that's always
still going to be true, right?
But you can say that such a
thing is a network motif, when
you say that these Z's
are only regulated by X.
So that happens
somehow more frequently
than what you would expect.
Although now that I just
said that, I'm a little bit
worried that even the
degree preserving would--
I think you have to be a
little more subtle in defining
your null model in that case.
But I'll just say
that this happens
more frequently than
you might expect,
which is that you have
one transcription factor,
say activating many,
many different proteins.
And this makes sense.
Because if all these
Z's are involved
in the same metabolic program,
then when you want Z1,
you also want Z2,
and you also want Z3.
So this makes a lot of sense.
But what is a little bit
less obvious perhaps,
is that it's possible to do this
such that you first make one,
and then you make the other.
And the way that you
can do this is just by,
you have different activation
thresholds, K1, K2, et cetera,
up to Kn for each of these.
So then if X is
turned on, so let's
say that you first
see something.
So this you actually have
to have X start at 0,
and then grow over time.
But then if you just have
different thresholds,
the question is where
should I draw K1,
and where should I
draw-- Do I draw K1
the low position or
the high position?
Low.
Perfect.
All right.
So we say K1.
Here's K2.
Here is Kn.
And then there might be
some others in between.
So the idea is that
X grows over time.
Then you first activate
expression of gene one,
and then gene two, and so forth.
And then the proteins
will naturally
appear in the proper order.
And there's actually
beautiful data
in chapter five illustrating
this in the context of our gene
biosynthesis.
So it's quite neat to see that
it's not just-- of course,
it's easy to think up this idea.
And say, oh yeah.
Maybe the cell might
want to do this.
But then it's
quite cool when you
see that actually in some
cases, the cell actually
really does do this.
And you can actually see that
they're expressed sequentially,
in the same order as they appear
in the biosynthetic pathway.
So this kind of gives you a
warm, fuzzy feeling inside.
I'm not going to make
you vote on whether you
have a warm fuzzy feeling.
But, yeah?
AUDIENCE: Could you also
have just some sort of Z1
required for transcription?
PROFESSOR: Ah, yes.
So you could have a
cascade in that way.
And that's a really
good question.
That would work.
But there's a problem, which
is that it's super slow.
Because there's a
characteristic timescale
for each of these things, which
is this cell generation time.
And here when I say you want
it after the other, what
I'm saying is you might want it
a few minutes after the other.
So in the context of
development, in some cases
some things really
are very slow.
Then that is actually
what happens.
There's a long cascade of one
activating two, activiating--
But in the context
of this, you really
want something that's just
delayed by five minutes each,
or maybe even just a
couple minutes each.
And in that case, because
really the range over which you
can have this sort of delay
like this, from the beginning
to the end, I mean this is
still-- it might be one to two,
say cell generations/lifetimes.
So you just can't get much
more of a dynamic range.
Otherwise you're going
to be in trouble.
Because you can't have this
be too close to the top.
Otherwise if you're a
little bit off, you're off.
So we really maybe we should
just even say one generation.
So that's kind of
how much of a delay
you might reasonably be able
to get from this mechanism.
And indeed, and
that's as much as
you would want for
something like this.
So this is great.
When I first read
this, I was like, oh.
I was feeling it.
Now the question is, after
this carbon source, or the need
to make our gene or
whatnot, after it goes away,
then we'll stop
making these proteins.
And the question is,
is this what we call
a FIFO queue, or a LIFO queue?
LIFO, LIFO?
It's been a long time.
I have a lot of faces that are
like, what are talking about?
So this is a First
in, first out.
Have you guys really
not-- you never
took any of these
computer science classes
where they talked about this?
And this is a Last
in, first out.
So just to be clear, what this
means at the grocery store
is that a first in, first out,
or a last in, in first out.
AUDIENCE: First in, first out.
PROFESSOR: It's a
first in, first out.
Right?
If you get in line first,
you get out first, hopefully.
And when that
doesn't happen, you
get very annoyed, and so forth.
But last in, first out,
this is for example
what happens in your inbox.
So you have a stack of paper.
People are giving
you things you're
supposed to sign or fill out.
And the pile kind of comes
up, and then you handle things
on top of the pile first.
So the things that get
stuck at the bottom
you never get to them.
And that's because that's
a last in, first out queue.
And so different, depending on--
well and in computer science,
then they can
choose these things.
And it's relevant and so forth.
But there are many situations
where this sort of idea
appears.
And so the question is, in
the single input module,
do we have a first in, first
out, or a last in, first
out queue?
I'll give you 15 seconds
to think about this.
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: What do you
mean by in and out?
PROFESSOR: So in
and out, what I mean
is that the concentration
of each of these Z's,
these guys they were
produced in some order.
Right?
So first we started producing
Z1, then Z2's and then so forth
up to Zn.
And what I want to know is what
order will the concentration
kind of go away in?
And you might want to
look at this figure.
Because it's going
to be super useful.
Any other questions about what
I-- all right, so in and out
refers to concentrations
going up, and then going down.
Let's go ahead and vote.
Ready, three, two, one.
See, I mean people learned
what FIFO and LIFO queues were.
And now already we can use it.
So this is a last
in, first out queue.
And in general, which
kind of queue do we like?
We like LIFO queues more.
Well, OK, you could argue.
But in this actuation would
we like a FIFO or LIFO queue?
I'll give you 10 seconds.
In a biosynthetic
pathway, would you
want a LIFO or a FIFO queue?
Yeah, and if you're
totally confused
by everything I'm saying,
you can do the-- flash
all the letters,
numbers, whatever.
All right.
Ready, three, two, one.
So there's some
disagreement we got.
But now a majority
of people are saying
that although the single
input module gives us
a LIFO queue, what we might
really like is a FIFO queue.
And can somebody say
why that would be?
AUDIENCE: We don't want
that much intermediates.
PROFESSOR: Right.
We don't want to pile
up those intermediates.
So just for the same reason
that we wanted to start with Z1,
and then get Z2 and so forth.
And the reason that
was because there's
no point in having Z2
until after we have Z1.
Because there's
nothing for Z2 to do.
It would be wasted
energy to make it.
In the same way, when we're
getting rid of these proteins,
we would actually like to get
rid of them first this one
and then later.
AUDIENCE: Why?
There's no point in having
Z2 if you don't have Z1.
You technically want to get
rid of them in the other way.
Because then if the carbon
source shows up again,
you want to have--
PROFESSOR: Well yeah, carbon
source showing up again.
I think that's a
separate argument.
So the reason that
we-- the statement
is really just that if
we first get rid of Zn.
Then we are just going to
pile up molecule n minus 1.
AUDIENCE: So the
metabolism is down.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
That's right.
So you can just
think about the flow
of those of the metabolites
and the molecules in there.
And you kind of want to
first get rid of this.
So then we stop making this.
And then we kind
of travel on down.
So there are many contexts in
which you would perhaps really
like to have a FIFO queue.
And indeed, one
of the things that
had been studied previously
was the flagellar biosynthesis
pathway.
So E. coli and many
other bacteria,
they make these flagella
that allows them to swim.
We're going to talk a lot
about that in coming weeks.
But in this context what
had been found actually
is that it is
indeed a FIFO queue.
So when they first start to
make these little flagella,
they make.
And it's a big
complicated, machine.
Right?
But they make it in the order
that it's transported and put
in the membrane.
But then when it
is taken away, when
you stop making the
flagella components,
then it's again
in the same order
as they were made in,
which kind of makes sense.
Now the question is, how
might we be able to do that.
So let me explain it.
The basic answer
is via an extension
of these feed-forward loops.
So it's what we call a
multi-output feed-forward loop.
What we have here
is we have some X,
and it is going to
come to Y. And then
Y again is going to do
this thing to Z1 and Z2,
and all the others.
But it's a feed-forward
loop, because we also
have X coming in here as so.
And I think that we do want
to have these be AND gates.
Let me just make sure I'm not--
no here's it's an OR gate.
So we're going to assume
that all of these inputs
are combined via an OR gate.
And what we have is we have some
K1, K2, et cetera, up to Kn.
Then we have another
set of K's which are
K1 primes, K2 prime, Kn prime.
So we have a set of
K's corresponding
to how X interacts with
the promoter at the Z.
We have different set of
K primes that tells us
how Y interacts with
the promoter at Z.
And the question is how
can we get a FIFO order.
I'm going to illustrate
some options.
And you can think
about it while I do it.
AUDIENCE: Are those
associations or dissociations?
PROFESSOR: These are
dissociation constants.
So these are again, this can be
thought of as the concentration
of the active protein
which it starts
being effective in sending
a signal to Z. Question?
AUDIENCE: Would you
not like [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: I hope not.
Because otherwise I'm
going to be in trouble.
Maybe for now let's, assume that
I've written the right thing.
And then we'll find
out soon enough.
Does everyone understand
the question here?
I'll just give you another
15 seconds to think about it.
All right.
Do you need more time?
Just a little bit more then.
All right.
Let's go ahead and give it a go.
Ready, three, two, one.
OK.
So we got a majority
B, but some C's.
All right.
So let's try to figure this out.
So what we assume
is that X comes
and it's going to do this.
And then it's going to do this.
And we can just have two
values for now, K1 and K2.
So this is X. Now
we're going to have Y.
And we can talk
about-- this is also
X star Y. We'll assume that
we always have these things.
So Y is also going to come.
It'll be activated
here at some time,
which we don't-- it's going
to be delayed by a little bit,
right?
Maybe.
So that's what Y is going to do.
Now we want to know
about Z1 and Z2, right?
Well, the idea here
is that it's going
to be the K, the regular
K1 and K2 that determine
the order that it appears.
We have an OR gate.
Y is going to be delayed.
So it's really, the important
thing is what the normal K's do
in terms of turning on Z's.
Yes?
And this is especially true
because Y is again delayed.
Because it has its own
threshold for turning on.
So since Y is delayed, it
won't really have a chance
to influence the
behavior of the X's.
And actually I should have
drawn this delayed too, as well.
So it's the order
of the K's that
determine how Z is turned on.
But it's the order
of the K primes
that tell us how the
Z's are turned off.
And that's again because Y
is delayed relative to X.
And we have an OR gate.
So indeed, in this case,
if we have like this,
and we want things to be in
the opposite order with respect
to Y. So if we wanted K1
to be less than K2, then
we actually want say
Kn to be-- I'm sorry.
We want K1 here, and then
we want Kn down below.
And the heart of this is
really because of the fact
that X is also regulating Y
with some other constant Ky.
And this is going to tell us
how much Y is delayed relative
to X. But the heart of this
is that since Y is delayed,
it's really the dynamics of X
at the beginning that tell us
how the Z's are turned on.
But it's the dynamic of the Y
and the K primes, K1 prime, Kn
prime, that tell us the
order at which those Z's
are going to be turned off.
So with the proper choice
of orderings of K's and K
primes is you can
then get a FIFO queue.
With that I think
we should quit.
Please read Sunney Xie's
paper very carefully,
because it's going to be focused
on a lot over the next lecture.
All right.
Have a good weekend.